hey I'm Samuel Andre Houston Mack let's
answer some questions from Twitter this
is wine support
[Music]
agent brown eyes ask why do people swirl
the wine glass around before they taste
it you see a lot of people doing this I
know it kind of looks pretentious but
there's a reason why people do this
basically what we're doing here is
aerating the wine the wine has been in
its vessel the bottle and it's been in
there you know a year or two you want to
open it up and you want to let the wine
breathe we expose the wine to oxygen it
starts to like break down the tannins in
the wine and make the wine a little bit
more softer and approachable at
Wanderlust ask sparkling wine versus
champagne what's the difference
sparkling wine can be made from anywhere
in the world so technically speaking
champagne is sparkling wine Old World
style wines are named after a place
champagne is a place located in France
and anything made in Champaign can be
called champagne any sparkling wine
Meats outside of the region of Champaign
in France can be only be called sparkly
one it's generally speaking when you're
talking about a sparkling wine this is
probably made with what we like to call
the injection method so cot is injected
into a still wine that it produces the
bubbles in it and you're talking about
Prosecco this is champagne how the
bubbles get in the bottle or a little
bit differently there's a secondary
fermentation that happens inside the
bottle use and sugar are added and the
byproduct that is CO2 that's the gas and
the bubbles that you get in it champagne
can only be made through the secondary
fermentation that happens in the bottle
add bokeh then one ask what are the
different types of wine grapes there's
probably about 11 of them but the ones
most commonly used in making wine is
called vitis veronifera so you have the
species and then from there you go into
the grape varietals you most commonly
know something like Chardonnay Riesling
sauvignon blanc or whites right Reds
Pinot Noir Cabernet Syrah so grapes that
are used in making wine are very
different than grapes that we consume
you know in our homes or we have in the
refrigerator the ones that we consume
are really big juicy and those aren't
really great for making wine with this
particular species the grape varados
we're talking about they're very smaller
clusters tightly bound you know they
have a little bit more impact on the
wine that they're making because of the
skin to pulp ratio so they're smaller
that means there's more skin to the pulp
that's in the inside of the grape those
grapes are much better for making wine
than say the larger and more juicier
ones at cutie with crohn's asks wait
what does dry wine mean how can it be
dry if it's wet in wine terminology dry
means that the wine is not sweet you
know you hear people talk about tannins
you hear people talk about body acid
fruit and that's just like the
fruitiness of the wine body is just you
know how it sits on your palate if it's
full body then it sits pretty heavy on
your palate and it kind of has like a
long you know a longer aftertaste light
body wines tend to like you know kind of
dance on the palate a little bit but not
as long or lingering and if you're
talking about tannin Oak imparts tannin
from the wood so it's this drying
feeling that you get in the insides of
your cheek very much like you can
experience that drinking like black tea
right when we talk about wine that's
aged for you know 10 20 30 years a lot
of those wines have tannin tannin is the
longevity at flight underscore wine
underscore bar ask why store wine on its
side and when you're storing wine over a
long periods of time it's important to
have the liquid inside the wine bottle
be in contact with the court this keeps
the court moist so it doesn't dry out
over time and become brittle and allow
oxygen to come in to the bottle and
destroy it but if you store it like this
you see that there's the Gap here but if
you store it on its side now you see the
cork is in full contact with the wine
here at Gene wandimi ask how do you read
wine labels When shopping slash ordering
we talk about old war wines which are
generally from Europe and then when we
talk about New World Wines which is
North America South America and
Australia so old war wines are generally
named after the place that they're grown
sanser is sauvignon blanc from the
sansea region of France it doesn't say
sauvignon blanc anywhere on this bottle
new world wines are generally lead for
it with what's actually in the bottle
they lead with the grape varietal so
this here it says Cabernet Sauvignon
then it talks about where it's from from
Napa and what's interesting in
California you only have to have 75
percent to actually put the grape on the
label each region has its own governing
body that lays out the rules for what
can be happening in said wine region
this bottle wine contains at least 75
percent of Cabernet Sauvignon legally
you can add different grape varietals
you know to complete the 100 blend atmo
163 underscore asks are we ever going to
discuss how wax Chardonnay is as a wine
and that it is the most inferior from
white wines some of the most prized
white wines in the world happen to be
Chardonnay it's all about your taste
you're an expert in your own taste me as
a Samuel I'm just a tour guide right and
I think there's been the blowback over
the years it was a movement called ABC
anything but Chardonnay and I think that
really pertained to you know kind of the
new world styles of Chardonnay you know
adulterate it with you know wood so they
come off very vanilla cinnamon very
toasty and slightly kind of ripe so a
little bit of sweetness in them so if
you think about you know mantrache which
is a very small Vineyard located in
burgundy in France those wines sell for
thousands of dollars and probably some
of the most sought after and rare Wines
in the world so it's just a matter of
taste and opinion I do like Chardonnay
up next at Ophelia Museum is ask there
are so many different types of wine
glasses who decided which ones
correspond to the wine type and how
there's lots of different glasses right
for different types of wine that you're
going to enjoy and I have a few here to
kind of show you traditionally speaking
when you look at a flute this is
something festive it's trying to capture
the bubbles showcase the bubbles here
what we call the Moose you know this is
a hybrid right so the idea is kind of
sleek almost like a flute another fun
way to be able to enjoy sparkling wine
so this is your white wine glass the
idea behind the white wine is it's going
to be a smaller glass right you don't
need as much air to surface ratio and
it's going to be a little bit more
tapered in you want to kind of be able
to capture the aroma so a white wine
glass tends to be a little bit smaller
than a red wine when you think about a
red wine glass it kind of acts as a mini
decanter that gives you a little bit
more surface to air ratio you can swirl
the glass and then be able to enjoy it
Port is what you considered a fortified
wine it's wine that's being made and
then you add alcohol to it to fortify
the wine it is served in a smaller
squatter glass smaller glass because
most people wouldn't consume a full
glass of this generally can be up to
like 17 19 alcohol at West Van Court ask
can you send a bottle of wine back after
you already started to drink it ideally
you're in a restaurant setting you can
always send it back right whether or not
they take it off their check is
something different when you actually
taste the wine you're tasting the wine
to see if it's sound not if it's good
generally people send a bottle of wine
back you know if it's defective right
you know if it's turned to vinegar or
what you generally see you know why
affected by cork tank cork tank if
affects you know one bottle and a 12
bottle case generally people don't send
back a bottle of wine because it doesn't
taste to their liking at Mayana asks why
are wine labels slash descriptions so
pretentious and what does a wine being
approachable mean I'm not trying to date
it so you hear something like
approachable balance like well when a
wine is balanced means that like if the
wine is overly fruity right then that
wine is out of balance if the wine is
too acidic that wine is out of balance
the idea of wine and when it's drinking
great and it's at its peak is when all
of those things are seamless a wine
being approachable meaning that wine
takes a long time for it to be ready to
drink when you say approachable wine it
just means that it's very easy to drink
and not as complicated I actually don't
use any type of wine descriptions I use
emojis
at arsenic 14 ask why does the wine
bottle have to have a Cork Wine which is
steep in Tradition we still continue to
use cork you know it's barked from a
tree mainly in Portugal so you know
that's limited resources so what you
start to see is synthetic corks
composite corks glass Stoppers and you
also see you know the screw cap does a
screw cap actually mean the bottle of
wine is cheap and I would say no and yes
this is the way I like to think about it
screw cap wines are generally wines that
are meant to be drank younger and
consumed younger a screw cap is all
about twisting the top off and getting
the party started I think for people who
are making premium wines and wines that
traditionally age over time cork is the
preferred method at ozxx ask WTF is
organic wine question mark question mark
upside down question mark upside down
question mark
organic is the is the way in which the
grapes are being grown not using any
pesticides you can go one step further
with the use of biodynamic who's created
back in like I think 1912 by an Austrian
doctor you know it follows the cycles of
the moon right but I think it's more a
conscious effort uh to taking care of
the planet overall it's bigger than just
if it tastes better right I think that
the practices and the things that you do
kind of really help preserve the earth
and the longevity of our time here next
question at this is Mayor ask so how
does one turn grape juice into wine like
how does the whole fermentation and
process work hashtag series question so
this process is fairly simple it could
be complicated in some ways you know
it's a different process for white and
red but overall the process is grapes
come in they're harvested they are
crushed and some places they do what
they call foot treading where you're
actually stomping the grape with your
feet a lot of times it's just put in a
vessel and then the weight from The
Grapes of the top actually Crush their
weights on the bottom and then you're
doing what's called punch down as the
grapes are like being crushed the skins
and the pits and all that kind of rise
to the top right and create a cap right
and what you want to do is kind of keep
immersing the cap down into the wine so
I can pick up color and all the nuances
that the grapes have to start
fermentation yeast is added so yeasts
are these little cells that are
introduced and they actually eat up all
the sugars and what's kind of different
is then they expel alcohol and then
after that it's bottled right there's a
few steps in between bottling filtration
clarifying the wine and then it goes
into bottles at baronhawk asks what do
you mean gulping isn't the proper way to
taste red wine so gulping uh insinuates
that you're not really even tasting wine
you in order to appreciate it I like to
think that like
you shouldn't gulp it but to each his
own we poured wine generally speaking
for a taste you just want to pour it to
the widest part in the glass I'm going
to go ahead and Swirl It generally I
like to swirl it before so I'm aerating
it let it open up I put my nose like
right here in the glass
so I inhale through my nose and exhale
through my mouth eighty percent of taste
is actually through smell so I'm really
opening up my olfactory senses
you heard that noise I'm kind of
swishing the wine in my mouth this is
all just aerating just bringing air over
the wine that kind of helps with you
know the taste normally what I do is
push the wine through the front part of
my teeth that you know affects my gums
in a certain way and that tells me
something about the wine if the sides of
my tongue start to tingle that means the
wine is high in acid there's not a
drying out of the inside of my mouth so
this wine tends to have low tannin so
I'm trying to confirm the things that I
smelled on the nose on the palate so
there's raspberry I do taste a tin of
strawberry a hint of cranberry there's a
minerality in the wine you know good
acid and then when you swallow you're
generally trying to see how long you can
taste it afterwards and that's what they
call the Finish at quickvit asks is it
only my wife who thinks the wine fridge
is necessary if you get to a point that
you like a wine fridge there is a
purpose to them they keep the wine at a
steady temperature is what you need you
want it at the correct temperature but
you also want it to be steady no vast
kind of changes in temperature so if you
pulled a white wine out of a wine fridge
that's normally at 55 degrees you
probably want to put it in the
refrigerator for a few minutes you
probably want to put it on ice red wine
served too warm just really accentuates
the alcohol so you get more of that
burning sensation in your mouth of
alcohol you want to serve your red wines
around 65 to 72 degrees something like
that at Marco Mariani underscore it asks
how does soil influence wine quality the
French they talk about terroir it's a
sense of place right it is Mother Nature
but it's also the soil right you know
you look at something like classic like
Chablis which is chardonnay from France
from the region of Chablis and that's
actually grown on like a limestone
really kind of chalky soil that really
kind of is the Hallmark and signature
when you're drinking Chablis right it's
that chalkiness to the flintiness that
you get and that's in part in the wine
some of the best soil to use is a loamy
soil right it's very kind of crumbly and
porous the idea when you think about a
grapevine is that it's Roots its roots
need to kind of struggle and that
produces some of the kind of the best
fruit and the only way to do that is the
roots to kind of dig deeper for water
when you look at your grape clusters you
want them to be slightly tight but you
want them to have shoulders that perfect
fruit in the way that it's grown has a
lot to do with the soil at dirty wine
glass ask hey why on Twitter question
for you how do you decide whether or not
to decant a wine what do you use as your
guideline vintage varietal producer
let's go ahead and decant so you have a
bottle of wine here and this is a
decanter you would decant a young wine a
youthful wine to let it aerate and to
breathe the second reason you would
decant is an older wine when you can an
older wine what you're doing is removing
the sediment from the bottle and that
allows you to have a better drinking
experience so to speak and now you
wanted to Camp so we're just going to
take the bottle we're going to rest into
my thumb and then we're going to start
to pour I think with more younger wines
you could probably be a little bit more
aggressive important in the bottle put
older Vintage Wines you want to go like
slow and steady you want to stop right
when the sediment is trapped in the neck
at unoi 918 ask do I really have to have
a degree to be a samoye what if I just
have good taste and like to tell people
what to drink assembly is really in
charge of anything liquid within the
restaurant in order to be a samoye
that's really a title that's anointed to
you by a restaurant although you get
hired to be a samoye there are
organizations that you can kind of go
through the ranks and reach some of the
highest titles one being Master samoye
another one being a master of wine so I
think the master Samuel a exam takes a
minimum of five years to pass I got into
wine by watching old episodes of Frasier
and from there I caught what we like to
call the wine bug at six does ask are
you supposed to have white wine with
fish the general consensus is white wine
with fish red wine with meat but these
are some of the old guidelines that
still exist within the industry most of
the local wine makers and towns and
people that made wine they made wine
that went with the local food so a lot
of times when I'm looking at parents I
start regionally I look at where is this
dish traditionally from what are the
ingredients with it and what did the
locals drink with it the idea of wine is
to help reset your palate back to zero
you can do it with a contrast method so
that's like having you know a pasta dish
with a very creamy sauce and you know
using a buttery Rich kind of Chardonnay
so you're matching like with light
another way to do it is to take that
same creamy dish and you want to do a
contrast you're going to do something a
little bit more higher in acid and lean
to help cut through the richness of the
sauce lots of different ways to kind of
combat it and look at it and it's more
of like taste than it is a science at
Jeff Bolton asks what is a cool climate
wine region how does this impact the
taste and the quality of the wines so I
guess the easiest way to kind of break
this down is think about hot and cold
everything about cold regions cooler
regions we can talk about like champagne
in Europe you know the idea that like it
actually snows in Champaign the
difficulty with growing grapes in a cold
region is that you can't really get the
grapes to ripen so ripe grapes means
that they have sugar so if they have
sugar in them this is how you start the
fermentation process by adding yeast
cooler climates kind of suffer but in
those years that you can actually get
the grapes to ripen enough cooler
climates are the best you get lower
alcohol you get more Nuance in the wine
and you get kind of these great acidity
you know acid is an amplifier right the
reason why you put salt on food limit on
Seafood is really to kind of crank up
the flavors of the dish and if you look
at hot weather it's kind of the opposite
right you don't want the grapes to get
sunburned right the idea of having too
much sugar in a wine can affect the wine
also so wines that tend to have more
alcohol tend to come from warmer regions
right and sit really heavy on your
palate at the meat Shack ask why does
rose wine exist Rose is a category of
wine much like white wine and red wine
and within that there's many different
grapes that can be used white wine
grapes to make white so to speak and red
wine grapes to make red rose is made
from red grapes with a slight skin
contact that gives it this pill kind of
color a lot of red wine bleeds clear
juice how it picks up its color is the
contact to the Skins the longer that
it's on the Skins the longer maceration
process and you get deeper color and
Rose it's just a slight contact with the
skins that produced us a little bit of
kind of pale color that you see here add
Robin brousseau ask what else is in this
wine besides grapes hashtag stupid
questions for some ways sugar can be
added to Wine right it's called
capitalization so it's illegal in
several countries in several regions
like you know think about burgundy in
particular sulfur is a byproduct of
fermentation so almost every single wine
has sulfur in it people use sulfur to
sprinkle on grapes and like sometimes
you can overdo that and I believe it's
somehow it's been linked to actually
people getting headaches from sulfur you
know byproduct of fermentation is
histamines and I think that's generally
what people are allergic to there's
actually more sulfur in a slice of bread
than there is in a bottle of wine but
generally speaking what you have in the
wine is about 95 water so those are all
the questions for today that was really
fun and interesting I could do that
forever but I just wanted to say thank
you so much for watching wine support